kann man das ging noch schneller als
gedacht und wir wollen das kriegt er
eine million zu abonnent stimmt halt du
hast du gute ideen was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
gut also meiner haut wirkt die creme
jetzt nicht so meins fühlt sich dann
haut ich kann das ja hier oben ist es
ein bisschen komisch also es naja
vielleicht meine haut dafür gemacht ich
hab gerade so krämer ausprobiert kann
ich jetzt nicht empfehlen aber du hast
mich umgedreht also falls irgend welche
rötungen entstehen werden dass videos
wundert euch nicht leicht haben heute
etwas ganz spezielles vor und zwar kam
ich glaube so genau heute vor einer
woche das video ich schmeiße ein paar
von meinen handys in diesem media mark
an die automaten
das ist ein automat da kann man handys
reinstecken der berechneten wert und
dann kann man sich theoretisch direkt
vom gutschein legen lassen und damit der
einkauf mein iphone 7 hat glaube ich mit
165 euro berechnet oder so schaut euch
das video sehr gerne an falls es noch
nicht gemacht habt und dort haben wir
top kommentar den top kommentare ich
euch sehr gerne mal hier ein und da hat
jemand geschrieben alex kauft doch bitte
mal ein ganz neues handy fax aus und
steckt sie den automaten und ich habe
auch erst mal überlegt vielleicht hat
man ein fake iphone testen oder so aber
wir haben ein letztes mal schon so ein
china handy probiert und das hat er gar
nicht erkannt
deswegen denke ich dass es
rausgeschmissenes geld wenn ich sowas
bestellen würde ich habe nämlich auch
keins mehr wir liegen und wir kaufen
jetzt mal neues handy jetzt kein mega
teures aber wir kaufen 1 und würde ich
sagen ich würde doch gut sagen kannst
einmal hier kommen hier das ist nämlich
der neue alex wie trainingsanzug den
gibt es ab dem 16 12 in meinem shop 1 16
12 vorkommen dass online kann man auch
in kombination kaufen ohren also ist
echt super bequem richtig warm und ich
hänge mich nur noch daran hat und
deswegen lass ich denn noch heute an
damit war schön als sie aussehen komme
ich auch ein ganz gerne als ding besorg
dir gar kein problem dann würde ich
sagen ab ins auto wir fangen jetzt erst
zu einem media markt
dabei ist ich hoffe die haben aus dem
automaten sonst kaufen wir da das handy
und fahren hat zudem moby letztes mal
waren wir mit den großen teams vor uns
letzte kurze planänderung eigentlich
wollte ich erst ein handy kaufen bei uns
da oben bei media markt und dann
eventuell haben wir halt gehofft dass es
da auch so ein automaten gibt ist nicht
so wir haben das gerade gewählt und
jetzt fahren wir direkt hier in die
stadt und den erst zu saturn kaufen ein
handy ich zeige euch das seinen
berichten kurs ein weil das muss man ja
auch man hat gesagt das habe ich
vergessen also als ein bisschen
einrichten wo dann stecke ich seinen
automaten und schauen wir mal ob wir
also ich gehe schon davon aus dass wir
den preis verlust haben aber man habe
ich kaufe jetzt endlich 450 irgend was
glaubst du schlägt dann der automat vor
ich denke schon ein bisschen verlust
also ich würde dann so sagen so jetzt
1920 war aber eher eine frage ist ob wir
das erkennt ob es halt noch gar nicht
benutzt ob muss er ja eigentlich dass da
nicht absolut nichts drauf ist es halt
irgendwie müssen spielen na ja die
technik nicht alle leute das malkurs
hier die frau weber ja gerne aber gut
ist und dann sehen wir uns gleich in
saturn 150 euro würde ich sagen oder das
hier
da musste ich mich abmelde dass ich das
haben will alter kammer ist nokia handys
500 euro
dass ich die dinger die wenn die akkus
in den youtube anschauen etwa 700 euro
das soll wohl eine richtig kleine kamera
und filmarbeit denke aber die macht ein
schlechtes bild noch mal ein foto nein
nein solange jetzt habe ich hier weg
erst mal zur kasse 153 euro
im internet ist das wahrscheinlich noch
günstiger oder
hier leider der ton versagt deswegen
muss ich das ganze ist natürlich nach
synchronisieren wir haben auf jeden fall
das samsung galaxy a20 meine ich gekauft
453 euro
und ich habe gedacht da wir schon auf
amazon nach ob es nicht günstiger ist es
gar nicht vor hier auch auf aber zu 153
euro
ohne scheiß ich ja darauf gewettet ist
safe günstiger aber gut da macht das
jetzt mal auf und dann machen wir uns
auf dem weg zum mediamarkt automaten wir
sind hier unseren parkhaus sind es
gerade untergang zu saturn wieder hier
hoch und auszupacken dann wieder runter
und wieder hochladen fertig es gibt ja
bestimmt nicht unter euch die ließen die
habe ich hier meine kommentare schreiben
kann das was fantastic doch jetzt ja
auch nicht gesagt willst du danach
behalten und pushen kann ich jetzt
wahrscheinlich mehr über ich habe die
ganze verwaltung zerstört und ist
einfach mal am automat verkaufen ist
nicht so dumm ist jetzt folie mache ich
noch dran das wm-ok geht an das ist
schon mal wichtig hast du dann noch mal
[Musik]
aber kommt mit kopfhörern sache
und die könnte ich ja eigentlich mal
testen da sind ja nicht mehr so was
lässt sich nicht und wir haben natürlich
den mini usb kabel sie gar nicht
schlecht aus das ihn einfach nix oder
den ganzen bildschirm ausgefüllt
halo ist komme hat sogar
gesichtserkennung fingerabdruck erstmals
das geld aber sieht echt hochwertige aus
150 herumkommen das ging noch schneller
als gedacht
und jawohl
romantisch spotify schon drauf
funktioniert recht meist also könnte ich
auch eigentlich verschenken so zu
weihnachten oder halt mal wieder
verloren aber dann musste ich mir schon
was gutes überlegen ich mache es ja ein
gutes ende das kriegt er eine million
zur abonnent stimmt alter du hast du
gute idee das so machen der erste dem
envio davon schick dass er der
einmillionste ist wenn er ganz viele
machen kriegt weist dann werden den park
noch ein paar härchen airport strom auf
jeden fall
dann werden natürlich nehme jetzt alle
abonnieren um mich dann wieder bei 999
1900 wieder zu deponieren
dann geht es wieder runter oder alle
warten bei media markt dafür kriegen
dass jetzt einfach so mit wie viel
besser zufrieden
vielleicht hat es jetzt ausgepackt da
fällt dann ein bisschen der wert aber
ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass es
jetzt dass sie mir da 50 euro begeben
weißt du also ich werde sehr
wahrscheinlich eh nicht verkaufen es
geht ja nur um den test lustig wenn es
mehr kriegen da mache ich doch mein
ganzes leben heute ihr glaubt es nicht
ich habe es ja wahrscheinlich nach schon
gezeigt erst einmal defekt da kommen wir
einmal wieder den ist der defekt okay
aber die mitarbeiter hat gesagt hey
wieso seid ihr eigentlich hier geht noch
einfach zu saturn die haben auch so ein
schon vor langem wurde
kommen wir zum saturn gefahren und
probieren den mal weil es ja auch den
kennen wir ja noch gar nicht sehr
praktisch neuland für uns deswegen nicht
sagen es geht jetzt muss es aber klappen
die haben da weiß ich auch nicht es gibt
hier zwei unterschiedliche
ja leute saturn war auch ein klub gibt
es nicht
so gut zu fuß
egal dann geht es zum monopoly diese
dumme mediamarkt mitarbeiterinnen die
meinte zu mir
aber den gibt es hier im saturn ich so
in welchem sie hat mir genau diesen ort
gesagt hatte ich mich einfach einfach
ins gesicht gelogen oder was die hat
sich so richtig angeht als wird sie sich
auskennen jetzt sagt ja aber dann gibt
es doch schon vor langem auch im saturn
am hansaring so das sind wir hier weiß
denn eigentlich jetzt um zwei stunden ja
ich will einfach die tage noch mal
probieren das sehen die zuschauer wie
auch wenn ich du deine videos gestellt
ja es ist echt auch wenn ich manchmal
machen wir dann jetzt das mcdonald im
juli
leute das geht ab guten morgen alter
gehören scharf stellen und dabei man
schon ich habe ein bisschen recherchiert
in bonn gibt auch von automaten deswegen
vielleicht jetzt noch kurz hin werden
wir zum nächsten tag ist gar nicht so
weit und dann ist dieses video projekt
wenigstens auch abgeschlossen weil sonst
hat man immer noch so irgendwie so einen
gedanken im kopf was war noch das machen
muss man das deswegen machen wir es
heute morgen ja wer märz 9 uhr
ich fahr los und dann nehmen wir uns
gleich bei media markt
ich kann den zustand seines tieres hast
du dein telefon dabei welche art telefon
möchtest du verkaufen zunächst an
telefon anderen tiere bereiten ihr dein
telefon für eine schätzung vorab mit der
bringen moment geduld während ich die
verbindung überprüft fantastischste
jetzt auch klappe schließen
keine sorge wenn du deine meinung später
geändert ich beurteile gerade dein
telefon modell speichergröße features
und zustand zu vermieten
träger 33 euro ich glaube auch wie krank
ist das denn alter einfach 120 euro
wertverlust also ist jetzt wirklich das
hammerharte oder an alle die sich jetzt
mal darüber aufgeregt haben dass ich ja
kein parkticket bezogen habe ich habe
übrigens schon wieder kainz gezogen
wollte ich nur mal kurz zu sagen hier
mit in der innenstadt gerne zu ich bin
jetzt wieder da juli wartet firma mit
der kamera so ich weiß du wirst du macht
habe ich bin grad nach bonn gefahren
juli war ja nicht dabei und ich habe da
dieses handy in automaten gesteckt
es hat ja 153 euro gestern dafür
bezahlen
weißt du was sie mir diese automaten
angezeigt hat muss 650 euro hast du
gestern auf 50 gesagt gesagt du warst du
noch bei 100 oder der hat mir einfach 33
euro wollten die mir dafür geben wenn du
schon so sagt es habe ich gedacht 50
oder und wer also das muss man sich mal
vorstellen gut ich verstehe es komplett
es ist ja nicht mehr komplett neue ich
hab's ja ausgepackt dann hat das
natürlich ein wertverlust
aber das ist schon eine sehr rasante
wertverlust theoretisch könnte ich
selbst einfach auch beim saturn
zurückgeben wenn richard die 153 wieder
vielleicht um einen ganz kurzen
vergleich zu ziehen ich habe mir damals
vor zwei jahren das iphone 7 neu
gekaufte 700 euro oder so und dafür hat
mir der automat immer noch 165 angeboten
das heißt ungefähr ein viertel sagen wir
mal und jetzt ist hätte man sich gestern
gekauft habe also dass gerade einen tag
alt ist da kriege ich nur ein fünftel
vom neupreis also iphones halten sich
anscheinend dem medienmarkt automat
länger oder so zumindest halt vom werte
also das ist mal war ich wirklich
begeistert von dem automaten dieses mal
mich so ganz aber es war trotzdem lustig
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen lassen
doch nach oben da abonniert alle fleißig
den kanal waiting room anmelden sagt man
dass du im auto von münchen aber ich
ganz oft in unserem
reisen ins all blacks wie und der
einmillionste abonnent der mir ein video
davon schickt dass er der einzige
million abonnenten kriegt das fucking
niemand wegen alle leute haben ein